well welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies all right yeah get
into it now fucking do it
drink the top layer did she ask us this
time to play for real something better
mati go for a bit the your innocent she
didn't homeless man it's time to fight
my brother Jimmy is old with joy this or
sex with your sister taking the face
dinner destroys the grandmother walks in
on you masturbating by would you rather
all right well it's good would you
rather we have a few submitted as always
you can submit your would you rather
stew us
your mom's podcast at gmail.com these
came in from mick poppy breath one of
them okay one of them did well let's
read his first tom would you rather have
a big healthy dick and your son has to
have a micropenis
Hajis or he gets to have a big healthy
dick and you have the micro penis kind
of really interesting question
mechanology behind that well the
psychology and also the love that you
love your offspring so much would you
rather them have the great thing or well
yeah I mean I've told us to you now if
it's between you and Alice dying I
choose you to die thank you I remember
that it's not really one of the
questions if you guys are in a boat
drowning I'd choose my son and you just
fucking die yeah I remember that I think
my answer to that was I'd hit you in the
back of the head with a fucking hammer
claw hammer
claw hammer and then my son would live
even though I even have to hurt you I
just know just for the added fun
yeah the added fun I'm making my death
hurt thank you
stab you in the neck with a screwdriver
and then I'd be like right Ellis let's
go I mean thanks for that but no but do
you understand that they're also saying
and this one do you would you rather him
suffer because he has a micropenis yeah
I know
or do you suffer and my answer is
honestly I would take the big penis
that's rude give him the micro penis you
know why why he denying better
he's a kid too baby small anyways right
now he's a baby doesn't need a big loser
let him have a baby penis for the rest
of his life you'll find other things to
get good at that's terrible yeah I don't
want to deal with it look I'm already
not packing a lot if you're telling me
to see the micro version of this well
yeah but you're married to me you're
already set up you have love I would not
dump you because we micropower to show
it off though I mean you know I pull it
out of parties I do you know I'm a
grown-up right so yeah having a big ol
healthy one
I'd be fun but you already lived your
life
you're old you're already 58 years old
I'm not done everything you want to do
yeah give your son the healthy hog um
Christina would you rather your husband
have the big nice one or your son my son
but you get to benefit from the big nice
one yeah but I've had my big nice I've
had 39 years of big nice ones
Puerto Rican ones black ones Haitian
Dominican ones it's time to let my son
have it all wrinkly you have the bigger
heart I'm taking the big healthy one
here's a selfish man he'll he'll be fine
um are you being serious
am I being serious yeah you're the worst
what all right let's totally if I have
to tell you why it's fine he'll be fine
you're horrible ma'am he's fine he'll
get used to it you know see I've already
experienced not having micropenis the
amount of psychological trauma
I would endure from accepting the micro
penis would be too much why you're
married it doesn't matter does matter it
doesn't not showing your hog to anybody
it doesn't matter doesn't matter no
thanks do you realize the amount of
psychological trauma going from a normal
one to a microbe like what that would do
and then just having it smelled on your
whole life exactly I don't know listen
this is a dick thing this isn't I got
yeah I'm the president of the Dixons I
know I know dude if there's one thing I
know in this world sticks and cocks and
ball and I'm saying I'm taking yeah all
right this is your domain your dick
domain
fine give one yeah go ahead okay would
you rather every time okay you can go on
a vacation once a year yeah for the rest
of your life free vacations anywhere
around the world but you're on a cruise
it's always a cruise and it's always
with your family oh my god for or you
have to spend a year alone in Alaska
Alaska great really think about it I
thought a long time it's not that hard
it's really simple
yeah all right hello Alaska
here I come Juneau but here's the thing
is that see an anchorage you do get to
go on a free vague
ancient it is a cruise it's not my
favorite Alaska fishing hunting a year
alone in solitude you go crazy a year
alone you're not talking to anybody
Alaska that was quick
way to go work for Sarah Palin yeah okay
join the Palin campaign for pay liver
President see here's the thing I might
choose the free cruise for a year
even though it's with every family
member that I fucking kick cannot stay
on this guy because here's what we did
on the cruise we went on last time you
buy that VIP pass that gets you in the
secluded areas of the ship you stay away
from people which is what we did last
time I would go crazy on that cruise
crazier on the face
I know crazier than being alone yeah
okay um is good okay
yeah Alaska yeah um but you rally you
take the vacation that's interest I
would because I love vacations yeah and
I would find a way I mean much like in
my day to day life I find a way to avoid
my family my family lives in LA and I
don't see I never I mean I I struggle
with four six seven hours with family
yeah so my dad's a different story I can
hang out with him dad's your des amis
yeah gang with him all day every day but
ya know how about this one came in would
you rather work at addy quality hotel
chain like a hotel six super 8 anything
with a number in its name he'll air as a
housekeeper for the rest of your life
ooh okay there are some brutal things
and you see a lot of shit
Oh later our house yeah oh yeah or eat
one dog shit sandwich per day for one
year and that's it I'm out after a year
I have to eat the whole sandwich doesn't
say a bite it doesn't say a bite it's
only two sandwich you get sick though
you get really really sick every day you
get violently ill no I'd rather just
clean hotel rooms for the rest of your
life here's what I would do bro
I will start a side business at that
hotel yeah that's so weed or something
or we'll work for big town you had a
pocket bid and not working right now or
I would start my own prostitution ring
in the hospital here you go I'm in
hospital
a hotel uh-huh I mean look there's
there's worse jobs and cleaning up hotel
rooms yeah I know but that's a rough one
Motel 6 is a rough one we're harsh yeah
gonna suck
yeah but eating shit is - I can't do
that dude yeah I think I would actually
do is say I just ain't accept this is my
life now there are gigs that I would
prefer to eat the dog shit sandwich
Shawn oh really which ones would those
be anything dealing with human beings
like having to touch them like old folks
homes like what if your job was to
change like old folk diapers every day
about massage therapist thing ah I would
hate to touch stranger that's the thing
we talked about
god I hate judging you all either I
would want to do that or what if okay
I wouldn't here's the thing yeah I
wouldn't want to touch me right doctor
when I see me yeah I don't know if I can
massage me here's a modified version of
this one because I think the thinking
behind this is is really good would you
rather be a prostitute for that asshole
what's his name high town big-time
because you're big town big town's yo
bake them wings bitch or you eat the dog
shit sandwich oh my god what I'm saying
like ya know then you'd be like I want
to get violently ill every right or or
you're like a Russian hooker
you're like a Ukrainian third-world
stolen from the Mafia yeah by the Mafia
mmm your drug with heroin every day and
you're 15 years old and you're the
prostitute yeah you know what I'm saying
like that's horrible - that's the worst
job poof ya mean like a wrench like this
shit yeah yeah yeah this one came in
I'll just read you this real quick from
Sebastian
um longtime listener first-time Lila
email time first time long time first
time would you rather have all your
Browns for the rest of your life be hot
toothpaste shits you know where you need
to wipe at least like eight to 13 times
I already are yeah and most of the time
they would be still brown back there
yeah that's what the bidet is for bro
these are long hot moist E Brown yes
where you spend 30 minutes on the toilet
yeah at that time wiping you never feel
clean yeah she's losing out of you
or would you rather have a dead
tooth in your mouth I like that that you
could not remove fuck that the dead will
be visible to everyone now oh it would
not be visible it would be like a molar
- now back your mouth I don't care it's
a zombie - but it would give you the
worst breath yeah that's the problem and
it would end up eventually decaying the
rest of your teeth yeah I mean you
described our Browns basic yeah so I
live with that it's like would you
rather live the life you're living now
or just have shit mouth so yeah sorry
said us young but we take current Brown
situation right oh yeah yeah definitely
definitely um hang else jeans yeah okay
I have wine are you ready yeah okay Oh
making you laugh yeah hold on though let
me think
that's the worst oh I know okay ready
wait well when I like this teeth idea
though so I'm gonna kind of tangential
off the teeth would you rather are you
listening to me have your front tooth
missing just one of your front teeth got
the right one just gone and you can't
fix it oh man you're just gonna have a
front tooth gone for like five years
yeah yeah or you're a DJ you get your
sweet DJ dad mouth or your I am a DJ
okay yeah but the only music you can
play is Garth Brooks and just got to
find a way to make it interesting you've
got to do gar drugs and do Garth Brooks
music you're Garth Brooks DJ but you can
only play Garth or you have to play some
Garth no no the only music you're
allowed your Oh catalog as a DJ is
everything Garth Brooks the fuck is
wrong with you
what's his head song is it gonna surely
stand
oh no that's not him he's got a mother
he's got I got friends
we're the whisky arts in and being but
you're like the cool dad Garth Brooks DJ
I like that yeah well the thing I really
like that front tooth missing I feel
about that you'd be like the toothless
comic the toothless retarded comic my
thing so my DJ appeal would be like come
to my show there's gonna be cool stuff
slick stuff neat stuff yeah I think I
would take the toothless retard family
yeah at least I could do what I wanted
it I don't want to fucking play Garth
Brooks but a missing tooth will ruin
your life first of all do you get it did
you lose me okay I lose you where I'm
missing teeth you would take my
micropenis but not a missing tooth and I
have to see your penis all the time yeah
you do you realize how it's gonna fuck
up your whole world missing a tooth
isn't horrible it ruins everything
you're not gonna want to smile I don't
want to look at you you stand a career
people are gonna be like it's like I'm
missing a fucking but that becomes part
of the act that becomes part of the act
man I'm the retarded toothless comic hi
guys
okay do you ever notice now you're
mocking do you get it do get it do you
get it what would you take
you'd be the Garth Brooks DJ yeah you're
out of your mind yeah cuz I could you
know find a way to make that interesting
you can mix like you can remix the beads
to make them cool know was loophole on
it there's loopholes you're not thinking
about Tom